hello or like we say in my language
zla i am tonitiv
the founder and the ceo of renewables in
africa
i used to be part of an engineering
organization in the uk
where i saw this very famous satellite
image
showing the distribution of power across
the globe
and i was literally in shock in cm why
up until that moment i never realized
how
serious the power situation was in my
beloved continent
africa i grew up in cameroon i used to
be in the dark with few lights
and it's up until you get confronted
right with
a different set of reality that you
start to understand the challenge you
are facing
this picture changed my whole career and
my whole life
our goal is to educate people and raise
their technical awareness
of renewables energy our second mandate
is to be an engineering company
so we bring clean energy solutions to
businesses
we may not be one of the biggest
polluters in the planet
we nevertheless within the brunt of
climate change
my mission is simple is to bring back
power
to africa and our vision is to turn
the dark continent that i saw in 2008
into a brighter and prosperous
one by 2040.
you